hello and welcome to this video let's
try to play a game I'm saying try
we are ready in this fantastic he do
heave and I really feel playing is tough
it's really tougher I have this Queen f3
at the end some other lines not sure if
this is some fully appropriate way of
playing against this early b5 yeah
anyway I mean it's probably a play that
option Queen on g3 ISM fairly annoying
piece okay
yeah I don't want to trade here Bishop
f4 looks good though uh-huh yeah if I
was attacked but is it dangerous
I mean Bishop d3 is a very normal
looking move on the other hand after
Knight f6 is immediately threatening
Knight Age 5
I mean it's it's a bit cheeky to take
this but he might do it I mean we should
be six looks let's do B should be six I
mean that's that simply looks like the
correct assume okay here Queen takes g7
is also possible and why not
exactly he might try for some
compensation I don't know how exactly
knighted you cannot even move the knight
it's not rid of a reason not to check it
so going to grab the look I'm not sure
why you have to play that quickly I mean
I don't think it was entirely lost which
is probably now Queen D for sure G to my
head looks good looks good anyway he can
still play Bishop g2 I wonder ever take
d6
hmm the ship z2 Bishop takes Queen takes
long castles is probably probably the
way to go okay
yet here I can just take and it's a
fantastic position and I really don't
understand if you are almost 12 and you
have three minutes on the clock in a
three minute game right but just just a
little bit of time once in a while can
be helpful to spend yeah III is a bit
lame but maybe I have to do it I don't
know 96 yeah now this I think is quite
comfortable actually I'm here the queen
is such an annoying piece you cannot do
mean for the bishop and I'm looking at
this very natural square
yeah Queen to be 8 and Bishop f4 B
should be 7 I mean that that is probably
still okay for black I mean I'm quite
happy but it's nothing special
yeah I know Bishop d6 that was um I'm
not sure that is really strong to be
honest something simple f3 is suggested
by the computer I have three knight f6 I
would assume and then we should be six
this is actually good yeah that makes a
lot of sense this is not a really good
movie queen e5 as strong yeah okay yeah
I mean I think I think he has to take
four and I wasn't really sure about it
to be honest and the engine gives black
a clear advantage yeah I would have
taken on f8 King takes and then check or
castling long and I was trying to claim
compensation and the engine says this
absolutely nothing yeah this is why I
was so surprised that he played this
like instantly I mean
funny enough it isn't even clear because
Knight f6 now instead of cancelling long
is still a game that is a really really
shocking move in some way so this
doesn't work and now yeah okay yeah
black is scanning enormous play here I
mean if you check this here Queen takes
probably as Queen takes and then this is
hanging and the pin this rook g8 that's
terrible yeah black is totally winning
and this is a funny line by the way
Bishop f4 intending Bishop c1 black wins
it's quite remarkable yeah but he had no
chance to find it because he was
blitzing every single move and here's
his totally lost sorry 24 yeah I think
he should take him yah-tchi one is
strong I didn't see that I wouldn't have
played the move this is essentially a
double attack so takes and n takes and
this is very nicely woman winning
position yeah okay this is awesome
completely completely gone and he
resigned yeah just a little bit of time
spend on the opening is helpful I mean
it doesn't really pay off to insta move
everything and the position was super
sharp and critical early on thanks a lot
for watching